[موسيقى]
ضوء قوي جدًا بالنسبة لي ، لكنه
أيضًا شيء أسعى بشدة
للاحتفاظ به ، حيث تعلم أن
الأضواء تنطفئ ، لذلك أنا أعاني من
أجل التمسك بالضوء
الذي كان مدرسة فنية في عام 79
قال طبيب العيون السيد.  سهم لديك مرض في العين ،
ستصبح أعمى في غضون 20
عامًا وقلت أوه ، أنت تخبرني بهذه الأخبار السيئة ،
سأقوم بعمل أفضل فن يمكنني
أن أصنعه على الإطلاق ، كما تعلم ،
سأفعل ذلك كما أراه  أضواء ساطعة للغاية
ولا يمكنني رؤية الضوء الخافت على الإطلاق ، لم
أر نجمًا مطلقًا في حياتي كلها ، على سبيل المثال ،
كنت أنظر إلى هذا المنظر باتجاه
مانهاتن ، ما أراه هو مساحة صغيرة جدًا
ربما حوالي نصف حجم
إبهامي  وفي كل مكان ليس
أسود ، وليس أبيض ، وليس رماديًا ،
إنه غير موجود فقط ، هكذا أرى أن
كل شيء آخر غير موجود ،
هناك عدد من
الفنانين المرئيين المعاقين بصريًا الآن ولدينا
وجه في عالم الفن
مثل الرسم هي عملية تستخدم فيها
عقلك بقدر ما تستخدم عينيك ، إنها
فترة طويلة جدًا من التعرض في
غرفة مظلمة باستخدام مصباح
يدوي ، سيكون الشخص هناك وسأطفئ
الأنوار وفي أي مكان لا
أرسم فيه  مصباح يدوي سيكون أسود
في
الصورة ، والخوف الذي يساورني بشأن العمى شديد
للغاية  إنه شعور بأن حياتي
لن تكون مجدية إذا لم أستطع قول ذلك ولكن بصفتي
شخصًا كفيفًا تمامًا ، سأظل
قادرًا على القيام بالرسم بالضوء ، لذا من
المريح معرفة أن عملي قوي
على الرغم من أنه ربما يكون في  المستقبل سنكون
قادرين على رؤيته
لك